[Music]
what do you guys know about [ __ ]
cheese frogs
cheese fried let's all say it good
cheese
what do you guys know so it's like
saying oh this is parmigiano reggiano
but in reality it's just parmesan that's
exactly right you could [ __ ] [ __ ]
anybody about cheese because it's like
certain cheese is like more expensive
than others
parmigiano-reggiano is like the [ __ ]
one right there it's the smelly one
that's the the most expensive one the
wheel one the wheel one what's your
favorite cheese
oh havarti
what is it called havarti
i'm kind of bougie i'm kind of i'm kind
of a princess it's a good cheese yeah i
like a i like a feta i like a queso
fresco and i like a parmesan i like a
craft i like uh i like ricotta too
ricotta is good
i like uh i like american cheese and a
burger or cheese on a dip or a [ __ ]
beaker beaker's cheese beakers nacho
cheese nacho cheese what about a brie
you guys like a brie oh mozzarella is
always good i like a brie cheese a brie
cheese and nice yeah like cheddar you
ever have those burgers where they
inject the cheese into the patty no [ __ ]
yeah oh america had that pretty good i
like the mexican cheese mix that you
could get at ralph's oh cotija cheese on
like
hot cheese bro
slept on them
dude nacho cheese at any [ __ ] sports
game yeah go [ __ ] yourself
with really good jalapenos though they
gotta have really sliced holes
is pimento a cheese pimento cheese yeah
i don't know yeah it's like it's like a
little peppery um
what was that dude's name and [ __ ]
the goofy moo the cheese whiz cheese
whiz that's what it's called cheese
paulie sure yeah probably sure where's
the juice his name's cheese uh so yeah
dude parmigiano reggiano's from italy
okay
kraft parmesan cheese is not from italy
yeah okay so a lot of casual new york
city cheese fraud is a serious issue for
producers
because they actually have a code that
they put into the rind of the parmigiano
reggiano
where they they they can tell which
one's real with this little chip oh it's
like a nft it's like another team where
were these nfcs where were these people
when everybody's selling fake kobe beef
everywhere we could have used that
certification yeah i agree but it's
harder it's hard it's harder to um
probably to put it into something to go
with the beef maybe but i don't even
know i'm really just making it up
because i think from my understanding
parmesan reggiano's like there's like a
really distinct smell it smells like it
smells like feet it like it actually
stinks but then like regular parmesan
you get from like craft it doesn't have
that smell at all and the taste is
different too
because i have two in my fridge i have
two both kinds you have the good [ __ ]
huh but it's from trader joe's though oh
so it's probably a fake [ __ ] parmesan
reggiano from chair joe's oh i see and
then kraft parmesan just parmesan i like
that one that one's good i'm trash
that's probably what we're used to as
americans because we put that on the
pizza i put it on the skeddys oh the
little foil like green
pringles can think yeah yeah yeah that
one's fire let's get down to the real
meat of this
would nfts solve being able to identify
the legitimacy of cheating the cheese
block chain yeah i'm sure so what
v-chain
i know
did you hear they just announced this
thing with the [ __ ] ufc like anyone
gives a [ __ ] right what they do with the
ufc the ufc is like the official blog um
blockchain sponsor of vechain but it's
like dude what the [ __ ] you guys doing
[Laughter]
anyway so yeah you're with crypto.com
though two decades is true for two
decades
parmesan reggiano wheels they use this
new unique alphanumeric tracking code
but now they're using this p chip micro
transponder into the label
so that way they're able to tell
which one
is part of which one do you know how
much like one of those wheels would cost
they're expensive
i don't know but the coolest part about
this is the p-chip
is a blockchain crypto anchor that
creates a digital twin for physical
items there you go so this scannable
tag is smaller than a grain of salt and
highly durable delivering next
generation visibility and traceability
but what if they lose it
yeah yeah whatever they'll never find
that means it's literally an nft it is
oh [ __ ] wow okay
so if it's that small how are they going
to know where to scan they know where it
is they know where it is arrow is
pointing to it it's over here it's too
small for the scanner and they're like
oh [ __ ] why did we why did we why'd we
put this in every one what if you ate it
yeah what if you ate it it's like
smaller than a grain of salt
you could if you could eat it
and then you're going to be a part of
the nft
damn we're the empty yeah
uh by integrating p-chip microtranspires
into these tags they can they can have
better control of their inventory
product origin and they can
differentiate their product against the
look and sound like brands that are
often faked do they successfully do they
tell you how they fake it oh yeah they
they make a similar cheese with a
similar method but it's not the one from
the
region like fake nikes regular it's just
a cheese factory
but then they put like a fake label yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like counterfeit
wine this is the real [ __ ] from italy
that we're talking about like the one
that so people are doing like
busted up like white label cheese yeah
and just calling it something that's not
full also it's not from that place from
that place so parmesan reggiano is like
a brand it's not necessarily oh oh oh oh
oh it's like calling something uh cognac
which means uh it's almost like a
another whiskey or whatever but because
it's from cognac france it's allowed
exactly exactly
because it's from the this it's from
this part of italy right um they say
it's one of the world's oldest and
famous cheeses it's a product that
symbolizes italian produce um and this
is the president of the parmigiano
reggiano consortium that makes sense and
they said since the establishment of
their consortium in 1934 they've worked
to convey the value of their product
globally and distinguish it from similar
sounding products on the market that do
not meet are strict requirements for
production an area of origin that
specifically is what's tied to this um
are other italians behind the
counterfeit stuff it must be the mafia
or is it asians oh
no it's for sure like a like a kendall
jenner some influencers just making
cheese on the side you know what i mean
or is it kind of like what happened with
olive oil remember that there's an olive
oil fake dude
they made they made counterfeit olive
oil for so long that people's palettes
adjusted more to that and now they
prefer fake olive oil because if you
look at certain olive oil like you look
at the actual ingredients
like a lot of the times it's a mixture
of different oils like palm oil
or they lie because it's supposed to be
pure olive oil but then like they mix it
cold pressed or some [ __ ] the green
glass bottle is olive oil is real olive
oil supposed to be i just found out
about this two seconds ago that's james
no but some of them say only olive oil
but they [ __ ] lie because they came
from a fake place yeah and then they
just mix that [ __ ]
but i get it but i mean the culture is
so like every like well not everybody
but cheese is so
it's a thing popular you know what i
mean that like i i can i get it um in
terms of like regions having a
specification in order to almost denote
both quality and like the authenticity
where it's from right it's like whiskey
without an e it's like oh that's
scotland or champagne from champaign uh
whatever the [ __ ] it is italy italy
france can just certain
only bourbon shut up
only bourbon comes from [ __ ] uh
kentucky right although if it's not made
in kentucky you don't get caught what is
it called then whiskey it's just whiskey
yeah what about captain morgan that's
rum right that's wrong dude you can you
can get some fire kenzie's jackets on
teespring
damn
i can't wait for the [ __ ] cargos to
come out dude redbubble the best kenji
shirts
designs you've never seen the ship is
free
teespring's cool did they ever did they
ever handle that the counterfeit king
just [ __ ] by the way it's always it it's
every year every every quarter you got
to find another one and then yeah so
what happens with things in demand right
supply demand yes it's just like
kendra's on teespring guys yes
it's really hard to tell the quality for
the two though you know what i mean on
t-string i feel like the logo is like
not centered
what do they do just take your logo
and then reprint it
they just make a whole other random
shirt do they actually design it can
just they'll take like a hinges like
changes tiger and word logo and then put
on like a hoodie but then they'll like
blow it up so that jpeg's not even like
super crazy so it's like 8-bit jpeg [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] it's kind of retro who's
doing it
if i knew joe
who's doing i want to find them like
charles or something
if it was someone in kindergarten
trying to make money on the side dude
would you would you be pissed with
someone from your own crew doing it it
depends on who it is wait who designed
it did john john she if it's uh yeah
john what if it was lawrence what's cal
yeah i'll crack up
i'll [ __ ] crack up i don't even know
how to be mad at that guy
what's lauren's doing that [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
that will put on his his suit because
he's going to work yeah and if he
[ __ ] has his suit on and then he's
[ __ ] selling kendra's merch on
e-spring
i would be i'd be so impressed damn dude
i think you should look into it i think
it is lawrence do that i just found i
just found this i just found this on
alibaba oh my god no it's lined with
like yo that's better than your [ __ ]
that feels like it'll keep me warm y'all
police bro
it's a quality garment i like their logo
too on there you can dance in the
wintertime summer's coming up dude just
buy it
do you guys even have that jacket [ __ ]
no
you don't like it yo but that's just
like snuggy material though
that's good [ __ ] man i'm getting one for
me i'm getting one for my wife
[Laughter]
not [ __ ] mr nikki limo green they
she'll wear it i thought the poker tour
to get some eyeballs on that [ __ ]
story yeah
and it's just a tag it's like alibaba
you're like either i feel like either
way you would win if somebody wore a
fake kindred thing because then they'll
be like oh would you get that you know
yeah but there's a better win where the
money went into our account
[Laughter]
significantly better win guys
you know what's really crazy is uh we
were in belgium for lmfo concert and
then outside they were selling all this
fake merch
and then uh foo was like uh
they tried to get the guys to leave like
but then um the police said no it's
better that we don't like [ __ ] with them
because the people that usually sell
counterfeit merch outside of uh concerts
in countries like that are usually the
local mob
and the cops are scared yeah they were
they were like it's better you don't
well they said because if you do that
then they'll try to they'll try to ruin
the concert somehow oh [ __ ] yeah they
could like start a fire or they could do
like something to just cause a bigger
problem so food bought all the merch he
just bought him out he said all right
i'll just buy everything
that's any big move he bought all the
fake merch so that the the uh the
concert goers wouldn't have fake merch
that's good oh dude why didn't he buy it
all and then sell it for a little bit
more this is in the kitchen store this
is not that good
that's a kindest jacket from the kids
it's just hey for cow it's lawrence i
know they go to the to the alibaba for
sure yeah there's no lining there it
doesn't look like it's warm
the cold is going to penetrate right
through it
that sucks
from the
there that's not a good quality
[Music]
you